yo what's going on it's fora make sure
you check me out on the bootleg Kev
podcast let's go
all right here we go bootleg cat podcast
we got a special guest in here my guy
for us in the building my man thank you
for having me new album Butterfly Effect
yep it's out right now yes sir
um why that name because obviously we
know the movie uh yeah shout out to
Ashton Kutcher also some of us might
know the movies dark movie weird movie
yeah yeah um I just feel like it kind of
in a nutshell like everything happens
for a reason and a lot of things happen
in my life where I felt like I wanted
this I wanted that and um I didn't get
those things but at the end of the day I
kind of accepted like kind of like
accepting fate Manifest Destiny kind of
thing and um you know everything kind of
just
worse the way it's supposed to and I
don't feel like I'll be here right now
if all those good and bad things didn't
happen when you say you wanted certain
things are you talking about like
industry type success industry life
um you know success whether it's success
love family things
um Financial whatever it is you know we
all want those things but sometimes we
don't get them well listen man I gotta
give you your flowers because I know you
like have kind of been through the
ringer in the music industry you've
obviously been on major labels you've
had a career that's spanned over a
decade now
but like dude you
are late bro it's [ __ ] I'm having fun
with it man it's it's it's a funny job I
don't know if you still have your store
on Fairfax do you no just uh okay but
you had okay you had that store for a
very long time on Friday right it was
fun most of these rappers couldn't sell
concert tickets let alone have a
successful clothing line right that has
a brick and mortar store on one of the
most expensive streets in America yeah
it's stressful man it's it's a stressful
thing to maintain well it's a big deal
while maintaining a you know music
career a brand career a business you
know what I mean all those type of
things are it's stressful but you know I
just have fun with it and I just kind of
you know even the album you put out was
it in 2020 or last album yeah yeah I
would love to yeah you did some crazy
numbers man yeah
fun I just have fun with it independent
hey all the [ __ ] I hate I I
understand that like
it's easy to like compare yourself to
other people or your peers or people who
you feel like oh man I I see them on you
know performing at award shows I should
[ __ ] all that bro like you've done a lot
and those are the things I'm talking
about like I want those you know award
shows I want to be at the Grammys here
be it you know this and that but at the
same time like I'm I'm kind of just
accepting of and grateful mostly of what
I have and what's been given to me and
what I work for but um you know I feel
like not everybody has a fair chance and
some people have advantages but at the
end of the day you just kind of find you
have to find what's you know what you're
grateful for well you have a hardcore
fan base and a lot of people would die
for that [ __ ] dog yeah like sometimes
you gotta like and I'm grateful for it
for real because I wouldn't be I
wouldn't be here still 10 years plus
after you know you got some like toxic
weird fans too yeah crazy I feel like
those are the best ones most of the
women who've I've come in contact with
who are big four fans are psychos yeah
been through a lot the thing is they've
been through a lot like crazy [ __ ]
yeah yeah been through been through a
lot of [ __ ] been I mean my personal
experience you're like yo I love Ford
you know foreign
you had a personal experience you had a
you had a she said some clothes on fire
or she's you know busted some windows
right yeah I feel like we we all kind of
been through that though for sure for
sure you might have had an extra crazy
one though no I just I'm not even women
I've necessarily uh had any sort of
personal relationship but just that I
know yeah I'm just like oh yeah yeah you
got like my wife's uh sister who's a
flaming [ __ ]
um she loves you but she sucks she's but
she [ __ ] loves you but you know they
might these people these people like
they might need something or someone
some of these some of these people have
not found the one yet you know what I'm
saying like somebody but they need
someone to really be there for them and
change their life I've seen it happen
too I've seen someone's life and
personality be changed in one day that's
that's a beautiful thing man
um how have you been dealing with uh
because you know I feel like you you do
live your life outward online sometimes
right
um you know I feel like we've kind of
seen you go through like public you know
issues when it comes to maybe depression
or you know maybe some of your previous
relationships just you kind of gone
through a lot of stuff and like we've
seen it how are you doing today
um that's a good question uh today I'm
still like the same person you know I'm
still kind of the same person but
I'm just less I try to be less open uh
on social media and everything just
because I don't feel like it makes
anything better but the reason why I try
to be open on social media is because
there's a lot of people out there going
through the same [ __ ] you know we're all
human you could be you could have 10
million followers 10 million dollars
like life's still going to hit you you
can't get away from life but at the end
of the day I feel like I feel like I'm
just going through the same thing but I
kind of deal with my
um you know my thoughts and everything
in a different way now right now that
I'm getting older I talk to people I uh
you know just have conversations with
myself but I still try to be open you
know have you gone to therapy I have
gone to therapy yet was it helpful
no it wasn't no no no how many times did
you go though I've been to three
different therapists and maybe I need to
find the right one that's that's what
they say but I um I don't know man I
feel I know it's supposed to be like a
judge-free Zone kind of thing but I feel
like when I'm telling my story I'm not
judging but they kind of don't get it
you know and it's it's hard to talk to
someone who doesn't get it when you say
this this and that and they're like um
but you know I I'm not sure maybe I need
to
[ __ ] you know what you need I don't know
what I need you need a hero's dose of
mushrooms
[Music]
that's what you need is that the truth
yeah oh man or you need to hop on a
plane put your lady go to [ __ ] Costa
Rica yeah do some [ __ ] Ayahuasca but
but here's the crazy thing here's the
crazy thing serious I know I hear you
and I've and I've heard that and I've
I've been told that but I love life bro
like no you're gonna love life more no
listen bro I promise you it's not a it's
I'm not telling you something like in a
negative way like yeah everyone not you
not just yeah anybody in the world
should do psychedelics
at least once
all the time
yeah here's the thing with me though I
feel like I have a great balance like I
love life but then like I hate life but
to you having having that pain having
that anger having that internal flame
inside me pushes me to do certain things
you know push pushes me to make certain
music for people you know what I mean
who who So like um Aaron Rodgers he's a
football player dude no okay so he's
[ __ ] back-to-back NFL MVP
this year he's been terrible but
two years ago he said he went to Costa
Rica did Ayahuasca and I like unlocked
something in his brain and he's just
like [ __ ] he's an amazing football
player and I mean he's always been
amazing but what changed he just said
that he like understood the world more
he became more self-aware he became more
like it it really kind of kills your ego
it kind of like yeah you should do some
shrooms at least I'm gonna try it I got
some for you I'll let you know okay
before you leave here you'll have some
okay
but I I like I like the balance between
between happy and sad though I don't
want to be happy all the time you don't
want to be happy all the time but you
also want to like have an understanding
of why you're yeah like there's probably
a lot of like repressed [ __ ] right you
don't even know is there right for real
like I had a my homie uh I would say his
name but he's an industry guy uh he said
that he he well I knew this guy to be
like one of the more degenerate pieces
of [ __ ] of like all time gamble did a
bunch of [ __ ] cocaine was always
sniffing blow off hookers boxes just a
psychopath right okay great guy though I
love him uh but he did Ayahuasca and he
hasn't uh touched drugs he hasn't
gambled he got married he had a baby he
got [ __ ]
wow he's like professionally doing
better than he's ever done like
Ayahuasca so what's Ayahuasca it's like
a um it's like a drink like a tea that
stems from a root that is
dmt-based but kind of like peyote
it's kind of different I'm not too
familiar with peyote but it's it's a lot
more intense uh you drink it DMT kind of
no DMT is like
yeah it is DMT but it's a slower version
of DMC like if you smoke DMT have you
ever smoked DMT no I haven't I can't say
I have yeah if you smoked DMT you would
just go away for like a half hour
Ayahuasca your present in the moment
it's like six hours yeah of like you but
you do it with a shaman
to work you through it you know
and they guide you they guide you and
then you come out the other side like a
[ __ ] like I my friend who we were
talking about told me it was like doing
30 years of therapy in six hours wow is
there anyone it
it hasn't worked for nobody I know no
one that went crazy like [ __ ] no I got a
couple of homies who like they go to
Costa Rica three times a year just to
get their [ __ ] like get just to get yeah
get their [ __ ] their mind right [ __ ]
hey because you know what like all that
[ __ ] all the therapy [ __ ] is cool and
it's helpful I think everybody should go
to therapy talk to somebody yeah
um but like the medicine that they try
to put you on is some [ __ ] yeah like
medication all this is some [ __ ] [ __ ]
like do some mushrooms bro yeah I'm
kidding it's not natural kind of thing
yeah yeah I feel like talking to someone
is important it is important but talking
to someone who kind of understands or is
willing to listen even if they don't
understand yes but the other thing is
you're in a position where a lot of
people you probably talk to
do they depend on you in some way in
some way yeah so don't talk to anybody
who depends on you for anything yeah but
there's there are also people who depend
on that aren't like that makes sense
selfish that makes sense of course but
you know not everyone is like extremely
selfish and some people are willing to
you know kind of step outside of who
they are and understand yeah I mean no
for sure man uh so this album what would
you describe this album as just in terms
of like
the motivation the message yeah you're
at I think it's I think it's just a new
me
um I took a two-year kind of break
didn't drop a project and before this I
dropped the album every single year
especially as an independent artist of
course you have to do that but I took
like a year two years off and um I kind
of just like did all the bad [ __ ] I had
to do did all the you know did all the
self-reflecting I had to do and just
kind of did everything and I feel like
it's a new me but at the same time it's
just kind of a uh just a recap of you
know what I've been through and and
everything yeah what's the uh the the
the the ju I forget the exact date June
what the song on the album The soon six
June 6 what's the significance of that
date
um yeah that's that that's it's a more
of a personal song I try to get real
like in depth and like deep uh about
someone who you know obviously I had a
you know something with but uh I felt
like naming that song not just because
um it's a real uh
I don't know that that day when that was
yeah yeah a bad day or a good day a good
day yeah a good day so I kind of do that
like reflecting on that and when that
day passes by I'm kind of just like you
know I I don't know yeah but you are
pretty outward with your relationships
online I feel like yeah I feel like it's
not
it's not that out of the box it's not I
mean normal people do that but do you
always like you're a famous guy right
you people people [ __ ] [ __ ] bro
you're late I like it man it's lit if
I'm with someone I like to I like to
show them off yeah exactly but is there
any like downside to that because I I
mean I'm not as popping as you but I
[ __ ] feel the downsides well I mean
what could be the downsize uh uh NFL
players hopping in the DM I mean
how about this I said Tupac I said Tupac
was overrated in an interview once oh
[ __ ] what and I didn't even mean it in
like he's overrated overrated I just
meant he's not top five he's like top
ten maybe you know he's like nine
through ten two yeah he's not top two
he's not
um I love and I love Tupac I'm a Tupac
fan yeah but dude there was [ __ ]
these Maniac [ __ ] Tupac fans
who threatened to murder my wife they
dm'd her oh wow yes yeah that'll that'll
get you that see and I didn't even say
it in a disrespectful way yeah
yeah
um so that's social media social media
is crazy social media is crazy but with
me I feel like I'm just I don't I feel
like it's better man to not really have
anything to hide and of course like if
you don't feel like putting your your
business out there it's cool but
if I'm with someone you're comfortable
with it yeah I'm comfortable with it and
yeah and like and like I said whatever
happens happens if someone slides into
the end you know NFL player and that
that's it for me and you know
wait I guess I get swooped on before no
no it hasn't happened
but I'm saying Aaron Rodgers
if Aaron
Aaron Rodgers
just Aaron Rodgers swoops and it was
that easy then it wasn't meant to be in
the first and if Aaron Rodgers DM's my
chick I'm gonna be like go ahead
go ahead you got to leave it up so give
me some [ __ ] tickets you got to leave
it up to the girl to the side I need
some good tickets it's all I need go
ahead handle it
let me hang out with him once a year
we'll go do Ayahuasca together like
how's my ex-wife she's good she's a nice
lady right shout out to Aaron Rodgers
that's a different level
um so for you man going from starting
out independently
you're on RCA right no Warner Warner
okay uh going through the major label
situation where it felt like they kind
of didn't know what to do with you or it
just kind of felt like obviously it
didn't work out how you probably had
wanted it
I'll tell you right now it was it was
just
um I got to do what I wanted to do right
but they also had to approve certain
things and um I wasn't feeling it you
know when not when I got off Warner I
was able to make music with who I wanted
to make music for anything blah blah
blah like but
when I was on on Warner I was like I
want to do a CL this is a perfect song
for this person I want to get this
record to this person I have someone
that wants to make it and they would
like
give their personal personal opinions
right you know um I even I just have so
many crazy like stories I wasn't only on
the label for two years but it was just
like you got all these people that don't
really know music right that want to
tell you how to make music and who you
should make music with and how you
should create music right you know what
I mean and it just wasn't wasn't my vibe
because you're not in there with to all
musicians you're in there with business
people suit and ties people who know
like finance and all that kind of stuff
but when it comes to the music like
there's no answers to this what up y'all
we gotta stop the interview real quick
tell you about our partners at mybookie
man look it's so much to gamble on right
now we got World Cup soccer we got bowl
games coming up NBA basketball uh of
course NFL man we're getting into the
playoffs in a few weeks well in like six
weeks or something like that uh with
that being said let's win some money all
right go to my bookie right now sign up
with that promo code bootleg and they
will match your deposit up to a thousand
dollars that's free money to gamble with
that's free money what are we talking
about my bookie uh let's talk about the
props you could bet on all kinds of
player props NBA points uh well Giannis
win MVP you can do Futures on the awards
season for the NBA uh so much going on
you could also still bet on the NFL MVP
odds as well there's just so much ways
to get money on my bookie but what's
most important is that they're giving
you free money you sign up and my bookie
right now you use the promo code bootleg
and they will match your first deposit
up to a thousand dollars that's right
free money what are we doing head over
there put in some bets and let's try to
win some [ __ ] money together all
right my bookie use the promo code
bootleg let's get back to the interview
you know what I realized is a lot of
these people in these buildings and
these major labels their number one
objective is to not get fired that's all
you care about yeah so they're like how
can I not get fired they want to avoid
risk right exactly right so their whole
thought process is okay I don't want to
get fired because I got a [ __ ]
Mortgage in these [ __ ] kids I gotta
feed and a side [ __ ] and all this other
[ __ ] yeah and artists are rich wrist and
I have this yeah I have this artist I
want to push him to do a song with I'm
playing the numbers game uh so-and-so's
got a [ __ ] viral hit or it's hot
right now let me try to push that
feature to happen even if it's not
organic yeah where you might be like I
would rather do this because it makes
sense and it sounds good and oh that's
I've I've got the credit they when I was
in Warner I mean no shade but I was they
they tried to push me to do so many
songs with these artists who's the most
random artists they try to have you do
right um I don't know just random like
EDM kind of I don't even remember the
names like yo you should do a song with
[ __ ] crazy upload yeah and then I I
was me by the way that'd be kind of hard
marshmallows fire yeah it just it just
has to it's two bad examples it has to
feel right yeah it has to feel right but
but I've been in the room and I've sat
with like the president and I've been
like oh you know we I want to do this
song or we're thinking about we want to
get this song done with there was one
time I was like I want to get this song
done with uh juice world and they're
like oh juice world like wow we don't
think that's like necessary or we don't
think that's uh early tour you know it
was early super early and they're like
oh we don't think and I was like it
makes sense like the sad music kind of
things
that would have been crazy they're like
oh no well we think you know we should
kind of turn that sad around and we
should do something more up-tempo you
know they always want the up-tempo kind
of thing I'm just like that's not me
that's not what I'm trying to do like
I'm trying to you know I have this
vision and they're like oh well this
song and these songs are doing good it's
just too much like
like analysis from people who aren't
really like
taking in like well they're just worried
about losing their job yeah that's how
it is and that's what it but sometimes
they think they
no just because you want to put numbers
on the wall bro but they think they know
based off previous numbers and there's
always going to be something
everything's always evolving yeah
exactly yeah for sure they go off the
past so now right now they're going off
like Tick-Tock and you know it has to be
like this it has to be like this because
this is doing good but what's after that
you know that Tick Tock thing is is uh
the best and worst thing that's probably
ever happened to oh music because it's
like it's dope because you get
discovered and if you know there's
people who've gotten discovered on Tick
Tock that are actually really talented
and yeah but then there's other [ __ ]
where it's like these labels are just
signing
it's like and then you hear the whole
song and you're like this is suck what
is this
but it's giving more power to
Independent Artists so at the same time
right because people you know you have a
hit song and you're just like [ __ ] I
Don't Need No Labels it also is good if
you're on it and you're doing the right
[ __ ] you're creating the right content
you're engaging with your fans it's a
like that's a way to pop your [ __ ] right
you know like uh someone who kind of had
a similar career path in terms of like
dealing with major labels starting off
independent ending up independent again
is like Snow the Product yeah she was on
Atlantic forever she's dope and they
[ __ ] fumbled that whole situation
then she got off and then she went did a
[ __ ] freestyle that went viral and
yeah and then it got Grammy nominated
I've seen it I've seen it I've known
snow for
for a long time years five six plus
years she's a she's a beast and she
really got that she got the Latin side
two or two so she got a wild thing yeah
yeah crazy she's super dope underrated
underrated super underrated what is um
for you having the type of fans you have
has there ever been a situation with a
fan that like they went a little
overboard we talked about that today I
had I've had stalkers I've had stalkers
I had people like waiting outside my
house like kind of thing like oh no like
where you live be with them yeah hmm
yeah crazy [ __ ] weird like real like
real story like stalker outside waiting
outside call the cops cops Checker dude
chick yeah girl yeah I don't know man
[ __ ] I mean nah but it's not it's not
it's not the attention you want it
sounds like oh wow but that sounds
terrible yeah it's bad you call the cops
cops come and they're just like oh and
cops leave you're like damn she's still
she's still here then what do you do
yeah you know and it's just like you
gotta get a uh
what's that thing called order of
protection man but what order of
protection
it's like where they can't restraining
order yeah I don't even know the
person's name or who they are or
anything about them and I'm like we're
all scared to go down there we don't
know if she's right there with a knife
or anything that's [ __ ] crazy then
you can't even sleep at night you're
outside the window yeah it's crazy it's
crazy would you say because you have had
some you've had some pretty crazy like
brushes with almost losing your life
over the years man
um was it last year that someone tried
to shoot at you we were going to Vegas I
think it was like last year two years
ago yeah and then something like that
also kind of happened in like 2015
it's only getting worse but do you like
when that has happened to you
uh I had a similar situation
uh
I didn't have anyone try to kill me I
almost killed kill my [ __ ] cell phone
not not on purpose
um but uh that [ __ ] like shook me man
like I'm like damn I could have [ __ ]
like literally died like yeah you know
I've I've had a lot of experiences with
that one thing I kind of learned is like
riding around with you know in the
Lambos and three Corvettes following
behind you and riding around in these
cars and just being kind of loud it's
not really like the smartest thing to do
or the safest thing to do you know um
and I used to roll around like that a
lot but these days I'm kind of like more
I'm just smarter about it I don't really
like the all the crazy loud bright
colored cars right because you seem to
be like a pretty peaceful guy yeah I
could get wild at times though no but I
just mean in terms of like you put a lot
of positive energy into the world like
to me your music is like it's not very
negative it's not like you're talking
like a bunch of crazy like but I like to
have fun though you do like to have fun
a lot of fun you do like to have fun
sometimes on Instagram
[Laughter]
but you know I just I the older I get
the more I realize like okay
I gotta move smart yeah because and I've
learned from a lot in the past but now
I'm just like okay if we go somewhere if
we do something we have to be strategic
and militant and you know move the right
way especially with what's going on you
know these days it's just it's [ __ ]
right now it's [ __ ] it's too crazy
yeah because LA's kind of always had
that element right but it's like I feel
like the EDD thing was so strong here
compared to everywhere else yeah I had I
had friends that were coming here from
out of town yeah to like commit EDD
fraud and they didn't have from here but
they were just getting money like
printing money yeah and that's what
we're talking about that too and I think
people are just getting away with [ __ ]
out here and they're just like [ __ ] like
not fearing the consequences and not
knowing like what's what's going to come
back so people are just down to do
whatever they were just like you could
find like a homeless guy and just pay
him for his social and his information
yeah and then
collect I [ __ ] I homies hitting the ATM
for like five or six grand every Friday
yes and that's it
and that's it and it was so easy I was
like what the [ __ ] is going on bruh
they're trying to convince me to do it I
thought about it I'm like wow I'm like
yo y'all are getting away with this [ __ ]
what oh no this is but what I fear no
this is [ __ ] I feel I've never seen
yeah that [ __ ] happens like I've never
seen people get money so easily in my
life so it was like scary it's almost
like the Bitcoin thing where it's like
yeah it might be a little [ __ ]
eventually like but what I fear is karma
though because it always comes back you
know yeah so I was I thought about it so
I'm like damn yeah
federal prison federal prison that's how
it comes back for you oh yeah oh yeah
everyone's going to [ __ ] prison right
now for sure especially with the ppps oh
my god oh man there was a gun I think
that that um that that that is also a
big attribution as to why like LA's kind
of gotten a little more crazier because
like people got a little bit of taste of
that you know and they want and they
want it and they want more so it's like
yeah are you pretty like uh careful
about like not like if you're are going
to go out to eat or something not
posting or like I mean even like course
leaving the story at home
oh yeah when I go anytime I go out
anywhere that's not like down the street
or if like I'm in a public situation
like this is a private situation so yeah
I mean everything you're doing a podcast
what if I go out to eat food like I'm
wearing shorts like dirty shoes and a
hoodie and like nothing no rain no
nothing and I'm just like No One's Gonna
twice at me because I'm just like I have
nothing for you bro you know yeah but
you could also I was I'm trying to push
this narrative to rappers to start
rocking fake jewelry yeah who gives a
[ __ ] yeah who's gonna request I've had
my share you know if you're a little
baby and you have a fake like [ __ ]
Rolex besides fake watch Buster he's
gonna call you out for sure yeah uh but
who's gonna question you the [ __ ] that's
what uh
no one could walk up to a little baby
with a diamond testing I'm like [ __ ] off
bro yeah like what he don't even gotta
say he got his security he got his
people man yo back up yeah you know do
you but yeah I mean it's not a bad idea
when you first got into the game did you
do the fake jewels of course just
because and it's less about like oh fake
jewelry but more like people kind of
give you gift you this and that right
and you find out like oh he's not giving
me real diamonds he's giving me you know
and it's cool like [ __ ] I'll take it
whatever it happened to me and I was
living in Tampa and shout out to my guy
Jane the jeweler he does all Russ's
jewelry great guy but Jane gifted me
this giant [ __ ] chain and I'm
thinking I'm rocking some yo [ __ ] it's
happened it's happened to me for sure
that [ __ ] was plated as [ __ ]
and and the Diamonds were not real but
if it's free it's free and if it looks
good on you [ __ ] it why not and if you
end if you get robbed you're kind of
just like take it yeah no my boy was
like he gave you that and he was like
let me see it he just held it he's like
bro that's not real nah I was like I
don't know [ __ ] about jewelry yeah
um how active do you plan on being after
now obviously you were talking earlier
you know you you're used to kind of
dropping yearly are you gonna make fans
wait a lot longer this time or no I
think I I really just it was just these
kind of like two years or that year and
a half and I needed to take that time
off to really kind of you know find
myself and self-reflect like I said but
now I'm I'm on go mode I have 100 plus
songs already in already already planned
out ready to come out so I'm I'm ready
to go in with being independent I kind
of look back on it I'm like why did I
wait so long but it's more of a personal
reason right because now in this day and
age especially you have to be consistent
you have to be 10 times more consistent
than four years ago five years ago go
six years ago you're in competition with
everyone now yeah it is everybody
everybody who has an iPhone you're in
competition with them and you're not
only competing with um
with other artists you're competing with
just attention yeah like I don't bro I'm
telling you bro like I'm a huge rap fan
and I listen to I listen to I mean I put
up my Spotify recap I think I listen to
like 28 000 minutes of music or some
[ __ ] but bro I'll be on podcast dog yeah
and and like I'm riding around I'm
usually listening to somebody talk about
[ __ ] fantasy football or sports or
Joe Rogan talking about Ayahuasca and
artists and musicians they're in
competition with that [ __ ] for sure
everything because you just need the
attention what are you doing in your
spare time these days like how do you
spend time it's funny you mentioned it I
gamble a lot I have a lot of fun doing
that we go to Vegas I play Everything
poker Blackjack everything kind of you
know I mean listen I happen to be a
degenerate yeah and it's uh same you say
that in a very like playful way but oh
it's not playful you've probably had
some terrible nights where you wanted to
[ __ ] it bro I've been at the casino and
I've genuinely thought about robbing
people
goodness yeah that's that's not not
recently yeah not recently but like 10
years ago like 12 years ago when I was
doing radio in Vegas and I'd be at the
[ __ ] Mandalay Bay across the street
from the radio station I'd be down like
three bands which is like my [ __ ]
everything I made for the month
I just started I'm like yo man go to
this [ __ ] high roller room and try to
catch somebody [ __ ] slipping yeah man
that's bad stay away yo what UPS bootleg
Kev gotta interrupt the interview shout
out to our good friends at Blue chew it
is cuffing season it's getting cold as a
[ __ ] outside right now and uh you could
definitely use a little extra
um fellas all right blue chew will have
your dick harder than goddamn
trigonometry all right so if if you
really really you know trying to get
your dick game right trying to make sure
your performance is at an all-time high
go to Bluetooth right now bluetooth.com
use the promo code bootleg they're gonna
give you a month supply for free that's
right a whole month for free
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg get your first month for free my
friend Adam Wade could use some blue too
that's for sure there he is so uh this
is what it is man it's got the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
in a chewable pill form form it gets
delivered right to your doorstep in
discrete packaging you don't have to go
to the doctor to get Bluetooth it's all
online all right and you get your first
month for free try it out and then thank
me later bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg plus they just dropped the new
blue chew mint chewable which has the
same active ingredients as Levitra and
that should have you [ __ ] rocked up
and socked up bud all right so one more
time bluetooth.com
use that promo code bootleg get your
first month for free let's get back to
the interview so do you do you um you
play Everything equally yeah everything
kind of equally you know what I learned
uh about gambling is everything it
opened my eyes to like not even money
but everything is relative you know so
when when someone loses a hundred
dollars it's like I've seen rich people
lose you know at a table in in an hour
I've seen them lose five hundred
thousand dollars but everything is
relative so when you see someone rob
someone or kill someone over you know
that hundred dollars you're like oh it's
just a hundred dollars right it might
have been there you know everything is
yeah exactly and every it kind of like
put everything into perspective for me
and seeing all these different walks of
life like play with all this different
type of money
and it's opened my eyes you know to like
to how kind of [ __ ] up and twisted
money is oh it's you know and it and it
made me value money a lot less right you
know how because I used to be like yo
this is what money is what we need to
survive but I've just seen so so many
things so many crazy when you gamble
they're it almost like desensitizes you
to the fact you're giving money away it
feels like you're playing a game yeah
because they give you the chips and it's
like oh this is little chips yeah this
is cute and then you walk away you go
you you go home at the end and you're
like oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] was real money
that's just rough yeah I uh the worst is
like uh
I have a friend who's made millions of
dollars gambling but I've also seen it
like he goes to the high limit uh slots
and he'll deal
you'll do like a thousand two thousand
to [ __ ] spin
and like I've seen him hit for like 900k
yeah like 1.2 million but I also see him
lose I've also seen him been down 300
000 in one day and I'm just like it's a
part of it my God what is your biggest
uh win in gambling and the worst nights
you've ever had in terms of losses wins
I've had bad knives but like just little
little nights
um my biggest win in gambling was about
quarter million on my birthday and it
was like I was like what the hell like
because I don't really like I believe in
luck but I believe in like
like reality too you know like I don't
think like you go to Vegas and right you
just you're gonna win because it's your
birthday but I won quarter million on my
birthday and I'm just like what what
were you playing [ __ ] black Blackjack
only what yeah quarter million oh my God
that was like a slow come up
no I was like one day no I mean in terms
of like you know some some people will
sit down at a slot machine and hit a
quarter million and [ __ ] like oh yeah
yeah or or they'll play roulette and you
know roulette you could win fast like
black guys it's not slow when you're
betting five thousand ten thousand it's
pretty fast you'd be there for three
four hours you either lose everything or
you win we have 250 250 and I'm like
that must have been the best birthday of
your life I was like this is so crazy I
was telling my girl I was like this is
like is this birthday look like what's
going on oh my goodness it was so cool I
can't imagine a better birthday yeah
ever yeah but then it also made me
realize like you know all this money
like uh it's it's
don't let me be up 250 on my birthday in
Vegas I'm gonna be at the [ __ ] I don't
know if you know who he is you you know
Mickey Mickey the dude he'll be rolling
around Vegas craziest that's mommy he's
he's like I learned from him the real
degenerate life like he's he's he's won
millions millions and a weekend stretch
there is like real like strategy if you
really gamble the right way that all of
it's luck based but there is certain
things like roulette there's certain
ways you could play with exactly where
you have like an advantage on the house
if you got a big enough bankroll uh
that's the the only the only Advantage
you have really in gambling you just
have to have the bankroll you know don't
try to be able to back your losses yeah
exactly so if you played you play Relax
yeah yeah so I've ever done the strategy
where you bet two-thirds at once so yeah
the second thirds third third first
second yeah
and then if you lose you triple each
time and
when I was living in Vegas yeah that's
what I would do I'd go to like Fremont
Street where it was like did it work out
for you mostly or didn't yeah but I'd be
there for like five or six hours and be
up like 400 bucks but for me at the time
I was missing that's 32 Grand a year
yeah it's it's all relative but
roulette's fun I like to bet on the
numbers because when that [ __ ] hits you
can't just get high you're like no
that's the dopamine hit of winning and
gambling is like nothing else yeah and
that's why it's a problem oh like when I
watch sports and I have a bunch of money
going on a [ __ ] game and it's close
and I win bro it's like I [ __ ] have
30 orgasms yeah no for real that's what
but that's why when I lose problems
that's why it's addicting I'm [ __ ]
sick
oh I've been there I've been there yeah
so my worst gambling stretches always
had to do with sports and it was always
sports betting from my house yeah
yeah because I've had some rough run
when I gamble man I really like to just
have fun right if I'm if I'm there
stressing or anything like that it
usually never works out for me right and
it's kind of a waste when you lose
because it's like damn you didn't use so
if you were up 250 in a night biggest
worst night that you've walked away um
nothing nothing bad because I don't I'm
not like doing anything crazy maybe you
know 10 20 30. I mean it's really like
that [ __ ] but you know everything it
kind of even I lost fortunes
I'd probably be divorced laughs yeah
I'd be like sorry shit's uh you know uh
I don't know what happened I thought I
was I
James Harden he [ __ ] up that's blaming
all the players yeah it's literally all
I could do right because I lost like 15
Christmas week ones oh no all right
Chris Christmas week that's what I just
blamed it on James Harden because it was
his [ __ ] fault
that's the worst Christmas week [ __ ]
James Harden yeah I love Vegas and
there's a guy named Mike White from the
Jets who [ __ ] started a game last
year against the Bengals cost me 10
bands [ __ ] Mike White too yeah you got a
sports gambling's fun though yeah I'm
just not too not too into sports I feel
like you have no control and the other
thing too is like you could also bet on
like these like really zany weird like
celebrity boxing matches yeah which I
haven't done yet I've seen yeah I have
not done that but there's like online
Sports books that will like take your
like blue face fight money or whatever
whoever you're fighting like yeah and
it's like those I feel like you could
kind of figure out what do you think
about tanking Garcia
oh uh who would win
I like Ryan Garcia yeah he's cool I
played poker with him before a couple
times nice I think once something like
that once or twice who would you take
oh man I don't I don't know tank man but
I feel like he's just the Beast yeah
he's also like the kind of guy that like
I don't know man some of these boxers
he's a he's like a [ __ ] he's like a
you know he might as well be a part of
YSL the way he'd be [ __ ] acting yeah
I like that [ __ ] I'm like bro you gotta
chill out bro you're a [ __ ]
professional athlete dawg like that
can't just be threatening people don't
want to be entertained man I like that
[ __ ] I'm like dog you're gonna get they
gonna put a RICO on you bro chill out
this [ __ ] beefing with every
rapper alive for real oh my God why are
you beefing with rappers yeah people
want to be entertained man people like
that [ __ ] no he's dope especially this
day and age you just got to be
outlandish crazy that's why six nine had
such a you know people want to be
entertaining still to this day when
someone talks about six nine they'll be
like yeah [ __ ] uh they might hate
them they might love them but they're
always going to say like I miss him on
my timeline he was entertaining well I
see this about six nine well in general
what you just said the Outlander [ __ ]
only lasts so long oh of course it's no
longevity in that
but at least six nine
who was pretty much mastered the
internet at the time right at least he
had some good records he did he had some
records that didn't suck yeah yeah I
mean yeah gumbo was a joint in the club
yeah bangers he even the Nikki record
was fire like that uh what was that [ __ ]
called Kiki Fifi Fifi Kiki whatever the
[ __ ] y'all know he'd be having these
[ __ ] weird-ass songs
but at least he had some records to kind
of back it up yeah but because it
wouldn't have worked if he didn't he's I
mean it would have worked momentarily
super a lot more gimmicky though yeah
you know it would have worked in the
sense of like little pump worked you
know and I guess they probably had
similar careers
and by the way for the second time in uh
uh [ __ ] little pump he put my number up
on his [ __ ] story [ __ ] him damn
because I had was it because the J Cole
thing yes you saw that right yeah oh by
the way I love J Coleman no no so me and
pump we're cool like I've always
defended him throughout the years yeah
we're a [ __ ] solid question to ask I
figured this kid might have been humbled
from the last few years let's have like
a grow up in conversation in which he
can actually kind of seem like a dude
and not like a [ __ ] clout robot you
know oh that was wrong
hey man some but sometimes I on that
kind of subject like some people don't
want to kind of admit kind of like where
they're at you know like that's the
thing is like you don't really
participate in a lot of that and you're
you have a a track record of like
like dude you've made more money off of
rap music than 90 of your peers and it's
not even close [ __ ] these [ __ ]
aren't getting royalty checked it don't
seem like it though no but they're not
getting royalty checks nobody's getting
royalty checks they're [ __ ] getting
their advance and then they're parlaying
that into show money or whatever the
[ __ ] but
[ __ ] ain't getting royalty
checks right like Meek Mill I think he
just said his whole career on Atlantic I
think he said yeah I've seen that it was
like a wildly low amount of money for as
many recipes like a million dollars or
something something crazy he asked how
much uh going bad made they're like 25
million he's like how much did I make
off that song no one told him anything
I'm like man so that's the problem
though like that's that those are the
that's label issues right there stay
away but this is the thing right like
it's a gamble because you could also be
the guy who's independent who well you
could be the guy who really ain't
who you might be a flash in the pan and
someone offers you two million dollar
deal yeah you better take that hey what
up y'all we gotta stop the interview
real quick to tell you about our folks
at hardean Las Vegas you see them right
there you know what I mean shout out to
hard D Man shout out to everybody over
there it's the uh illest dispensary in
the world number one they got the
craziest selection of weed you'll ever
go to when you're in Las Vegas there's
only one place to go that's hard in you
pull up you say hey I heard about this
place on the bootleg cat podcast and
they're gonna get you hooked up with
some [ __ ] weed all right so go to
Jardine Las Vegas right now if you're in
the city of uh sin or you're going make
sure you uh you know put it put together
a little hour off to the side and make
sure you go get your nice [ __ ]
Harding bag full of uh just a premium
weed all right and not only that you got
to shoot them a follow Harding
underscore Las Vegas I'm gonna shout
them out though because Harding smells
the best the dispensary is just it's not
only the best dispensary in the world
it's the best smelling dispensary in the
world and look now the bootleg kit
podcast smells like Jardin because I
have the hardine signature scent candle
you could have one too you could go to
[ __ ] Hardy in Las Vegas just saying
also make sure you follow them online
Harding underscore Las Vegas that is
important you have to follow them
because there's some [ __ ] accounts
out there we appreciate hard Dean when
you're in Vegas pull up go get you some
smoke go get you some edibles go get you
some [ __ ] carts whatever it is they
got it and they got it at the highest
quality it's the only place I'm smoking
from that's Hardy in Las Vegas let's get
back to the interview exactly and that's
how people think sometimes Lil pump did
that he got a bag and good for him you
got to bet on yourself and when you're
an artist and if it happens quick then I
get it but if you're if you're building
up and building up and building up and
you see it's working for you and you
have a shot in this [ __ ] bet on yourself
man gamble on yourself and and [ __ ]
don't take that quick money that
you know instant gratification Build It
Up keep going it might take five years
but where are you gonna be yeah you guys
like rest these days who like kind of
like pimp the label for two albums and
then got the [ __ ] out and still owns
this Masters and now he's you know like
he just drops a song every week or every
two it's like you just do what you want
you feed your fans yeah and that's it
that's another thing but it's also aside
from the label thing it's not following
the trends you know because I don't
think I don't think he followed like
super trendy like what was going on in
the music when like when pump was hot
like you know there was a lot of people
trying to do that you know coloring
their dreads doing all that little pump
is like he's like the uh he's like the
clout era like mascot for sure but
everybody followed his whole [ __ ]
those every three years or every four
years we we give it like six nine Loki
followed a lot of like the pump [ __ ]
even like oh yeah I mean I mean just
[ __ ] shocked you know what I'm saying
shocked yeah value there was the uh [ __ ]
I'm not even gonna say the dude's name
because I was dming with him
Chief Kee set the tone for a lot of [ __ ]
too there's there's there's a bunch of
people the Clone Guy what's his [ __ ]
name I was just dming with him because
he's mad that I forgot his [ __ ] name
clone
kid boo kid boo yeah shots kid boo I'm
gonna have him on the podcast we're
gonna have a really honest conversation
about his whole [ __ ] thing but
that was like yeah an egregious
era of of music oh it was all it was I I
think they call it the SoundCloud Era
SoundCloud I want to say Supreme not
everything Supreme Patty got a record
deal I think he did no way Supreme fatty
uh Supreme Patty the lemon juice in his
eyes guys put out a record that was
produced by Scott Storch wow shout out
Scott that's my guy get the bag yeah but
I'm pretty sure
somebody gave him a deal I don't want to
speculate on which company it was yeah
but let's just say
it's a number that the company is named
after a number I'm pretty sure they gave
him a bag I might be wrong but the fact
that and supreme Patty's a nice kid but
the fact those kind of people are
getting record deals in the cloud era
let me let me let me say this man the
industry these labels it's it's like at
first it was like embarrassing but they
tried to hide it now they just don't
have any Pride like they're like [ __ ] it
we're already embarrassed they just did
the [ __ ] the fake crypto rapper yeah
they're like we're already [ __ ]
losing we're just gonna [ __ ] go all
out you know how when someone just gets
super desperate to [ __ ] just start
doing [ __ ] and they're [ __ ] you're
just like dude you have no [ __ ] shame
I feel like right now that's where we're
at with [ __ ] labels they're just like
oh he has a [ __ ] hot Tick Tock five
seconds snippet like we need them we
need them it's just it's embarrassing
that fake uh AI rapper uh that Capital
signed and then dropped within five days
because of the outrage
what was the name of that [ __ ]
do you know what I'm talking about there
was like this meta rapper who was like a
oh my bad
it was like a fake rapper right that
they made on the metaverse okay and
FN Mecca right so that dude was not a
dude it's a [ __ ] like an avatar that
was like saying the n-word in its music
and like I never heard it I'm surprised
I never heard of this bro it was all
over the place for about two weeks
but so so Capital announced that they
signed the first ever AI rapper right
yeah but then once you dive into it
you're like oh this is just kind of like
like a lot of black stereotypes and the
people behind it from what I understand
you would know more than me because she
worked with I'm not sure that the
person who created it was black am I
tripping
the guy behind
the guy was white exactly
right right so it was almost like the
Milli Vanilli thing but with like a
cartoon gotcha right and it was just
like it was the cringiest [ __ ] I've ever
yeah what I think what I think is
labels and all these things they they
want like instant gratification kind of
thing like they don't value longevity
anymore they don't value good music or
just artist development yeah or artists
develop that but then I get it because
so much shit's going on they just want
to grab you know grab whatever's coming
the numbers game man they'll sign up uh
50 acts and hope one of them becomes a
weekend yeah but the Independent Artists
like me and and you know all these other
artists that are doing it the right way
we're we're playing the real numbers
game we're trying to make we're trying
to be here for 20 years what's your
distro is are you doing like distro
Foundation oh you do for Shout Out My
Guy Lee yeah shout out Lee Lee when I
was when I was on when I was on Warner
Lee was the radio guy at Warner of
course he was yeah he just announced
today he's got he's got a big big thing
coming shout out to my guy what is he
doing what is he doing he just left
Geffen oh wow he announced that today so
he's going to uh well I can't say where
he's going yeah yeah my my distribution
Foundation is done I I want to say more
for me than any uh well then Warner then
you know and Warner had my Mass
yeah foundation's a great company yeah
amazing company and the one thing about
Foundation is you just call Lee and be
like hey yo
what I'm you know I'm trying to drop
some [ __ ] tomorrow let's do it all right
let me call the stores we'll figure it
out yeah let's do it yeah shout out to
hey that's dope I didn't know you were
under Foundation that makes sense though
yeah I've been with them for about two
years I did my last project with them
too it makes sense yeah and that last
project was did numbers bro yeah you
were on hella playlist yeah and that's
in in foundation help with that like a
couple of years ago you were you were I
felt like I said I was like Forest kind
of hanging out with some of these
industry douches a little you gotta try
to pull them back in a little bit yeah
yeah I almost got pulled back into it
I was like oh there were certain people
mentioning you to me that I was like
yeah you've like yeah you had some seven
figure deals on the table I bet you did
I might need this right now like I bet
you did but it's when it comes to
building catalog you gotta really you
gotta you gotta bite the bullet and
think long term right you know
especially for me for me if I if I only
made music for two years and I have a
seven figure deal on the table I'm like
of course let me take it you know but
now I'm kind of like man I've had this
is that seven figure deal did that
include your independent catalog no okay
well then that's that's different
because you know a lot of that's what
they're doing now they're like we want
to roll up your whole [ __ ] everyone
wants catalogs enough everyone for sure
but um but yeah I was like I have songs
that are already making seven figures I
have songs that are you know not albums
just singles that already did seven
figures like I just need to push another
one or two of those out I don't need to
sign for four albums sign for three
albums with you yeah and like if you
have like um a lot of dude I mean
[ __ ] you got songs with people that
the fact that you were able to have a
keilani and Janae feature on an
independent project and like you know
that's a big deal man that says a lot
about your relationships that you built
over the years yeah and it takes it
takes Ryan it takes hard work and
especially artists of that statue well
those are also the type of artists that
have high artistic uh Integrity don't
want to work with someone and you can
make the greatest music but they don't
want to work with you if you have any
you know bad [ __ ] attached they also
like aren't the type I'm I'm assuming
like you just can't pay for like
features from some of these artists oh
no come on
they got to be great for sure it has to
be something that's like yeah I'm gonna
do it most of the time you know those
are artists that'll really just get in
there and just do it and create because
they love music this way I mean it's
weird because I'm in both Industries you
know I mean I'm in the r b and I'm in
the rap and I see the difference I feel
like the r b side they really appreciate
music a lot more and they're less of
like trying to bang out a bunch of songs
and just get in the studio and [ __ ]
I'll put this [ __ ] out they there's a
lot more Integrity behind it you know in
the rap world it's a little more
aggressive like ah [ __ ] it we'll just do
this [ __ ] it's a lot it's a lot more
like fake and toxic and twisted for sure
well I mean like I think like you I mean
nowadays
you know guys like Rod wave are
considered hip-hop I mean I'm sure like
sure he's got like you know yeah but
it's like
you guys are really just doing like kind
of like your own thing like you know
it's almost like when like people would
consider post Malone a rapper I'd get
like sick when I would hear that out
loud because I'm like he's just an
artist yeah he's an artist
to me you're an artist yeah like you
could rap you could do this seeing
melodic [ __ ] but you're like an artist
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah
but you know they're and but there's
those worlds like rap world where it's
like like these are rappers like Dojo
cat is a rapper technically she raps
yeah she's also listening too though
yeah she's a pop star bro like she's a
[ __ ] yeah when I say like yo she's
the hardest female rapper I'm like
but then you'll get really look at her
in that lens yeah maybe yeah but you'll
get into those Industries where it's
like this is this is r b this is like
these people are the most r b you could
get like you know that r b [ __ ] is fire
and um I think rmbs have like a dope
like four or five year run of kind of
coming back and yeah
the Soul music side of shits like uh
yeah there's just been some great r b
[ __ ] getting made that's like kind of
like underground but not underground
yeah right it's like shots like
selection radio and apple and stuff they
did a good job of kind of like they've
been in Russian pushing that line yeah
for sure hey we got to stop the
interview to tell you about our family
at odd sucks that's right the most
comfortable socks in the [ __ ]
world go to oddsoxofficial.com right now
use that promo code bootleg and you'll
save 20 off Christmas time is it coming
and let me tell you something their
Black Friday sale if you're watching
this before Black Friday you might be
watching it after Black Friday but if
Black Friday hasn't came yet just like
Cyrus hasn't came yet it's been a while
he's on a drought guess what
oddsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg 20
off plus whatever the [ __ ] else is going
on with their Black Friday sale and let
me tell you they got some new licenses
we got to talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist
and shout out to all you rappers and
people who be pouring your lean into
this [ __ ] some Mountain Dew Baja
Blast socks
Casino great [ __ ] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board you know what I mean we
get to put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [ __ ]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[ __ ] [ __ ] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [ __ ] ethica or
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Nike socks
[ __ ] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview
um so the album is out
not a lot of features no
Skye and Garen yeah Garen Skye my girl
she did amazing oh that's your girl
that's her girl yeah oh wow just in the
studio vibing was she an artist first
um did you like say Hey try this yeah no
she she showed me stuff like when we met
she showed me like you know singing
stuff and I was like wow like you're
really good she's like uh like I just do
a fun type thing I'm like but you know
just get drunk in the studio and Just
Vibe and have a good time and whatever
happened whatever we create and feel
good about we just kind of put together
like that but yeah she's she's amazing
and talented and yeah I don't want to
make it work man if you put her on your
album I know right imagine my plan one
of the songs with her goes like double
Platinum right and then you have to
perform it and you guys break up like I
feel so bad for our good friend G-Eazy
because like me oh man that's my guy not
me myself and I the [ __ ] him and I
mean I yeah that record is a smash he
has to perform the song but it's him and
his ex talking about each other but you
know I think I think and this is kind of
how I see it too like like once again
like whatever happens happens and life
can lead you in a million different ways
but I've seen him perf I've seen him
perform it without her after the whole
thing too and and I think um you know as
when you grow when you get older as
adults you kind of just accept certain
things and you realize like you know
what this was a beautiful thing at the
time this was a beautiful moment at the
time and I'm still gonna respect that
instead of letting that eat away at me
or or become bitter about it what was it
like touring with him oh man Maniac [ __ ]
right
yeah they set up like the let's say
let's just say it was fun they set up
like the little pre-party and after
party little section still house yeah
Vibes trippy was on that tour too with
us
and trippy yeah we're we're I had to be
a lot of fun real debauchery yeah yeah I
think I might have signed a contract I
could not say I can't say anything I
didn't sign [ __ ] but some of the best
nights of my life with that crazy white
man yeah it was fun man Jeezy's an
amazing dude man trippy is [ __ ] seen
a lot of success bringing that [ __ ]
cinnamon apple [ __ ] still house and
the mint still house
by the way he's not with Stillhouse
anymore from what I hear from what he
told me actually so uh yeah uh well look
man I appreciate you pulling up
um go support the new album Butterfly
Effect it's out yes sir morning music on
the way anything else is the clothing
line still booming obviously yeah man
we're we're uh rebranding the clothing
line um I had some
I just had some internal kind of things
conflicts and stuff like that where I
had with you know people I trusted and
people that didn't really um you know
suit
what I was going through and you know my
uh views on things but
um I stopped I I had to step in and kind
of control everything and and rebuild it
the way I wanted it uh it to be right
but just
so much [ __ ] I spent so much time on on
the brand and um I think uh
yeah just bringing in people that you
know weren't really good for me or
whatever and you know being able to
um trust people I trusted people that
maybe I shouldn't have or put too much
trust in the people I'm gonna be honest
bro I've met two or three random dudes
that said they they were your manager
over the last like three years for uh
for sure and I'm like I don't know I
might I don't know if I'm the problem I
don't know if like what they're like
very random dudes yeah right be like oh
yeah that's the homie come hit me yeah
and then I give him my number and then
they just keep hitting me on some like
hey yo it's for his manager and I'm like
bro the industry I mean you know but
it's it's crazy you just gotta be
careful who you keep around you bro
right right and I'm learning I'm
learning that because I usually because
I move with good intentions of course
and I expect the same of others and I
think the same of others but
it's not always like that you know how
many people have like fora or yours
truly tattoos too many oh we're we're
looking at pictures the other day some
straight like my face you know my whole
like from upper torso just tattooed like
it's crazy it's crazy the Yours Truly
logo too like it's it's insane man every
time I see it if someone gets your face
tattooed on them
is there a benefit that comes
um that's that's a good question I mean
you're not a direct benefit but if I see
it I'm just like I'm gonna remember them
forever right you know [ __ ] you you
gotta pay to get into the show
not like that if I you know in in even
people that don't have you know my face
or my name tattooed like I I connect
with my fans group chats of course you
know Instagram pretty accessible to your
fans yeah it's almost like yo I got your
name tattooed me and my sister and me
and my cousin want to get in like I'm
like yo I'll put you on the guest list
easy I want everyone in my shows that's
super you know I don't I'm not like oh
[ __ ] you have to pay the 15. yeah
because if it gets out of hand and you
end up like you know like Tech Nine and
Strange Music where like all their fans
have like some sort of tattoo then
you're not [ __ ] making any money on
the road but that's where you want to
get man because it's not about ticket
sales or album sales it's about people
you want to touch the people yeah and
they're that you someone tattooed
forever you know they're they're a fan
of you forever you know yeah I've seen
that work the um bad way too with ICP
tattoos oh yeah the hatchet man yeah
they're crazy yeah Juggalo Juggalo Vibes
yeah there's like 50 year old dudes
teaching [ __ ] seventh grade that were
ex-juggalos nice and they'll never be
able to get rid of if you've been to
Gathering of the Juggalos I actually was
I've never been but they tried to book
me to do something there in like 2015
and I was like once you go Juggalo you
never go yeah I want to go I would love
to I think they get a I think they get a
bad bad rap because I think they're
really like good people I've seen a lot
of like videos and stuff on like
Gathering of the Juggalos
and they're really their whole model and
their whole thing family family for sure
you know and I love that it's like a
cult kind of thing it looks fun yeah it
looks black white Latino there's a [ __ ]
Hut there yeah it's crazy and people
it's like a it's an open free
environment there's a drug Bridge have
you heard about the drug Bridge no but
it so they got a bridge sounds like some
juggles and you go to the bridge yeah
and it's anything you want man but it's
living I gotta give my respects of those
people because they're for sure for sure
you know shout out to the Juggalos I'm
from Phoenix we got nothing but Juggalos
there
but they gotta I heard I mean this is my
boy jelly roll told me jelly rolls like
a jelly roll yeah he's done he's like
bro they got a [ __ ] tent there that's
just you just go in and everyone's
[ __ ] and he's like bro but it's like
the type of people you don't want to see
[ __ ] he's like bro they look like me
bro hey man everyone needs someone the
stench in that [ __ ] is crazy
everyone needs someone can you imagine
like Juggalos don't have the highest
personal hygiene based on my experience
with them over the years and I've had
vast experience with it yeah and I've
been to some ICP shows
that whole ICP cottonmouth Kings Strange
Music [ __ ] yeah
yeah shout out to them guys they're yeah
good people they just misunderstood
let's call them misunderstood did you
grow up like you grew up in Cali where
the cottonmouth Kings popping I mean I
don't know they might have been done I'm
from Anaheim they're from uh Riverside
are they from they were OC guys I mean
maybe some some might have came from OC
but I think they're it's a seven it's an
I.E thing the hot the high white socks
the little Spade socks and the big
monster trucks cottonmouth Kings yeah
SRH yeah
Stoners wreaking havoc yeah yeah look at
us all right all right shout out to the
IE that's what I eat man appreciate you
pulling up brother yes sir what a guy
fire